Hey,
They were probably
I don't
Good evening.
So glad you joined us this evening. My
name is Cat. My pronouns are she, her.
And whether this is your first visit,
your first time here, or your first time
in a long time. We're glad that you're
back or we're glad that you're here and
that you chose to be with us tonight.
The sixth anniversary of the table is
coming up in November. And to celebrate
that, yes, you can apply. Go ahead.
We'll stop and let you do that.
And to celebrate that, we are having a
chili cookoff next Sunday. So, pull out
your favorite recipes
and bring your chili. We have plenty of
plugs for crockotss.
and bring that next week.
Uh, if you need to sign up, also on the
QR code is the place to sign up for your
award-winning chili.
We would appreciate that. Our next
service day for Five Loaves will be uh
it's a food pantry will be Saturday,
December 6th at 9:15 to 12. if you'd
like more information on that or to sign
up uh the QR code as well.
If you are anxious about being in a
church setting,
uh we have a bucket over there that has
some coloring sheets, fidget spinners,
noise cancelling earplugs,
things that might help you out a little.
So feel free to stop by on your way and
you can Drop that off on your way out.
These candles are a sign of the presence
of Christ
among us, fully divine
and fully human.
Now let's come into our call to worship.
Now we exit
the kingdom of noise.
hurry and productivity.
And now we enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness,
and grace.
Now we enter sacred space,
a space for prayer,
worship, and adoration.
A space to encounter Christ.
Revelation of God.
Heartbeat of creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you, to mend your heart.
May we all come home.
Thank you, Cat.
If you guys would stand with us, we're
going to get started with some worship
this evening. And um before we do, I
just wanted to read this passage out of
Ephesians 2.
It says, "He came and preached peace to
you who were far away and peace to those
who were near. For through him, we both
have access to the Father by one Spirit.
You're no longer foreigners and aliens,
but fellow citizens with God's people,
members of his household, built on the
foundation of the apostles and the
prophets, with Christ Jesus himself as
the chief cornerstone. In Christ, the
whole building is being joined together
and rises to become a holy temple in the
Lord. and in him you too are being built
together to become a dwelling in which
God lives by his spirit.
Ephesians 2 has been an encouragement to
me this weekend as I've been kind of
reflecting on some different parts of my
faith that have uh changed over time and
shifted. And it's easy for me to kind of
almost forget like the beauty and the
simplicity of the cross and this this
God who showed us sacrificial love. It's
easy for me to forget and kind of get
lost in all the nuances of it. But when
I come back to this picture of Jesus
laying his life down sacrificially so
that all of us, those who are far and
those who are near can be joined
together as his children coming together
to be built up into his house. That
encourages me. It It's something that I
want to come back to over and over.
That's what we're here for. That's why
we're worshiping this God because
whether we're far from him or near, he
made a way for each one of us. He made
space and room and he calls us his own.
So, I want us to sink into that tonight
as we sing to him that we are children
of God. We together are his people. We
are his house. Um Jesse's going to get
us started with multiplied so you guys
can follow along with him and sing out
if you know it. And if you don't, just
um I encourage you to reflect on the
words and open your heart tonight. Try
to trust this God who is good, who's
made room for you, this God who loves
you.
[Music]
Your love is
like radiant diamonds
bursting inside us.
It cannot contain.
[Music]
Your love will
surely come find
us like blazing wildfires.
singing your name.
God of mercy,
sweet love of mine,
I have surrendered
to your design.
[Music]
May it offerings
stretch across the sky.
These hallelujah
be multiplied.
[Music]
Your love is
like radiant diamonds
bursting inside us.
We cannot contain.
Your love will
[Music]
surely come find
us like blazing wild fires
singing your name.
God of mercy,
sweet love of mine,
I have surrendered
to your design.
May this offerings
stretch across the skies.
These hallelujah
be multiplied.
[Music]
Hallelu.
Halleluah.
Halleluah. Sing hallelu.
Hallelu.
Halleluah. Sing hallelujah.
Halleluah.
Halleluah. Sing halleluah.
Halleluah. Single.
God of mercy.
Sweet love of mine.
I have surrendered
to your desire.
May this offering
stretch across the skies.
These hallelujah
be multiplied.
[Music]
Hallelujah.
Be multiplied.
[Music]
All right, you kiddos are dismissed to
go to your classes.
Thank you, kids ministry, for helping
them out tonight. I know Maitlin's back
there, Maggie,
and many others who are helping show
these kiddos the love of God. Thank you
guys.
And as they leave the room, we're going
to transition into prayers of the
people. So, you guys can look up to the
screens. The parts that are in red,
we'll read aloud together. And then in
the middle of the prayer, we're going to
leave some space for you to share um a
person or situation that you're carrying
heavy on your heart tonight. And we just
want to lift those up before God
together. And then we'll close out the
prayer.
Jesus, for this city of Saxi, Texas, and
for every city and community, and all
who live in them, we pray to you for the
good earth that you have given us and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it.
We pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and the orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you.
[Music]
Seth
the darkness
you push it away.
[Music]
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace and a deep sense
of your presence.
Amen.
[Music]
Come tear down the walls are built up.
Every wall are built up. Every wall are
built up. You deserve every piece of my
heart. Every piece of my heart. Every
piece of my heart. Lord,
I am trusting that you are a faithful
father. All that you have is good.
>> You're a generous giver. Your love's
like no other. Won't you come and break
through to me over and over and over
again? I am bringing my heart to you
with open hands.
Closer and closer. You're drawing me in
as the depths of my heart lay before you
again.
Come tear down the walls I've built.
Every wall I built. Every wall I built.
You deserve every piece of my heart.
Every piece of my heart. Every piece of
my heart. Lord,
I am trusting that you are a faithful
father and all that you have is good.
You're a genous giver. Your love's like
no other. Won't you come and break
through to me over and over and over
again? I am breaing my heart to you with
open
closer and closer. You're drawing me in
as the depths of my heart, baby, for you
again.
Come tear down the walls I build up.
Every wall I build up. Every wall I
build up. You deserve every piece of my
heart. Every piece of my heart. Every
piece of my heart.
Over
[Music]
and over and over again. I am bringing
my heart to you with open hands.
Closer and closer. You draw me in as the
depths of my heart lay before you again.
Come and tear down the walls I built up.
Every wall I built up. Every wall I
built up. You deserve every piece of my
heart. Every piece of my heart. Every
piece of my heart.
[Music]
I' heard a thousand stories of what they
think you're
the tender whispers of love
in the dead of the night as You tell me
that you're pleasing that I'm
never alone.
You're a good good father. It's who you
are.
It's who you are.
It's who you are. And I'm loved by you.
It's who I am.
And I've seen many searching for answers
far and wide that I know. We're all
searching for answers.
Only you proide as you know just what we
need before we say your word. You're a
good good father. It's who you are.
It's who you are.
It's who you are. And I'm loved by you.
It's who I am.
Love so
uniable.
I can
hardly speak. Peace so
unexplainable.
I can hardly think as you call me.
Deeper still as you call me.
Deeper still as you call me. Deeper
still into love.
Love love love. You're a good good
father. It's who you are.
It's who you are.
It's who you are. And I'm loved by you.
It's who I am.
It's who I am. You're a good good
father. It's who you are.
It's who you are.
It's who you are. And I'm loved by you.
It's who I am.
You are perfect in all of your ways.
To
the end.
You are perfect in all of your ways.
You are perfect in all of your ways
to us.
You are perfect in all of your ways.
>> You are perfect in all of your ways
to
come tear down the walls.
Every wall are built up. Every wall
built up.
You deserve every piece of my heart.
Every piece of my heart. Every
>> one more time.
>> Come tear down the walls I've built up.
Every wall I build up. Every wall I
built up.
You deserve every
[Music]
piece of my heart.
God, we can open up our hearts and our
lives to you because you showed us your
great love.
Because you laid your life down for us.
You made a way for our story.
You pulled us in all your people from
all the corners of the earth.
Those living in light and those living
in darkness,
those with plenty and those who are in
want.
The righteous and the unrighteous God.
You pull us all together.
[Music]
God, would you remind us of the gift
that we have in Jesus? Would you remind
me of the goodness, the faithfulness,
God, the forgiveness that I've been
shown
that I can be made new each day?
That I can live in grace,
God. That there's room for me.
Remind us of the love that bought us.
[Music]
Make it new to us again. Where we have
forgotten it. Where we've grown callous.
where we've allowed busyness or pride or
confusion, God,
to take up space in our heart. Would you
tear down those walls and would you meet
us in your love,
[Music]
in your redemption,
in your grace?
And would we live as children who are
loved by you.
[Music]
Continue to speak to our hearts tonight.
God, help us to be open to listen to
your words, your voice. God, would it
ring the loudest in our ears above
anything else?
It's in Jesus' name that we pray all
these things.
Amen.
Would you guys turn to the person on
your right and left and say the peace of
Christ be with you and then you can be
seated and Brett will start our message.
Well, grace and peace. It is good to be
with you all. Uh my name is Brett. and
the pastor here and yeah, a joy a joy to
be with you to welcome you into this
space and uh as always that includes
those joining us online. Um and anyone
here tonight who is new if this is your
first time or just your first time in a
long time we're really really glad that
you're here. So let's see we are in this
is week three. Next week we'll be
wrapping it up um our current series
titled the end. It's just a new
beginning. And uh so this this is a
series about esquetology and uh like
last things. And uh basically this is
like really honestly my first time to
ever do uh a series like this. And I
don't know if it's just me, but I'm
hearing some kind of feedback. Um so I
don't know, maybe I'll scoot back. That
might help. Sometimes it does. Um but
yeah, I've never done a series like on
this, you know, this topic. Um and I've
avoided it for I think mostly for good
reason as I've kind of covered if you've
been here for the weeks. just feel like,
man, we just really in the church get
like wild with this stuff. In fact,
actually, next week I'm wrapping up,
I've realized, um, as I've been writing
this, I've really focused a lot on sort
of the return of Christ and judgment and
kind of doctrine of like hell and heaven
and kind of all that. Um, so next week I
wanted to get into like some of the
other somewhat random kind of topics um
that I don't know I think people may
expect when it's like what do you what
do you think about the book of
revelation you know or I don't know what
do you do you have thoughts on the
antichrist or you know so I'm trying to
kind of do like a catchall just random I
don't know and hopefully it'll resonate
with you or you'll find it helpful. Um
it was fun to write I will say that but
um yeah so that'll be kind of next we
getting into some more wild stuff. Um,
this week I wanted to kind of wrap up
all the the thoughts we've been working
through, especially last week, but into
this week on um, kind of hell and
judgment and all of that since it's such
an area that I just feel like as
churches, we really need to rethink
this. I really feel like Christianity a
lot of ways has become like a religion
of fear. At least in certain circles,
that makes it sound small. In like major
wings of the church, it has become like
a fear. That's almost just the way we
preach the gospel, you know? It's like
um yeah, kind of scare them into heaven.
In fact, just this week, my kids, they
went to a haunted house and they were
like, "Have you ever been to a haunted
house?" And I was like, "Well, I guess
not technically, but I have been to a
hell house." And uh which is like the
Christian version where they try to, you
know, present the gospel, kind of scare
you to death, and then present like,
"Hey, you've just witnessed hell. Do you
want to believe in Jesus?" You know,
it's it's kind of like this. Um so,
yeah. So, there's just a lot I think we
need to really um rethink, re-imagine
here. So, I hope it's been clear as
we've gone. Like, I really
Don't think of like hell, judgment, all
that as some weird crazy torture chamber
of God or something, you know, like I I
really adamantly oppose this idea of
hell as eternal conscious torment. I
think this is like a disaster. Um, and
so it's tricky though because I am still
using the word and you know, I mean,
it's it's been kind of challenging to
know how to talk about it without like
triggering people. Um, but at the same
time, I know if you go to your Bibles
and read the Bible, you're going to find
that language there. You know what I
mean? So, um I don't want to just like
not talk about it or just, you know, not
mention then you like don't know how to
grapple with it, you know, as you come
to it. So, um at any rate, uh we'll kind
of wrap up that that element of things
uh tonight with the title of my message
is we're in this together. And our
primary scripture is Romans 11:32, which
if you were here for week one of this
series, you'll recognize uh since it is
uh just a great kind of example of the
apocadistasis,
um which is the the great Christian hope
for the restoration of all things and
really all creation, all humanity uh
healed, restored, made whole in in light
of the love uh of God. And so this is
Romans 11:32. For God has bound everyone
over to disobedience so that he may have
mercy on them all. One of my favorite
verses in the scriptures. So incredibly
hopeful. And uh I I think you've kind of
been able to tell, you know, as we've
gone through this series that um I
really do think a little bit differently
about the end of all things. Um, I
really do think that it's uh like right
now all creation groans as we've talked
about, but one day it really will all be
healed and restored and made right um in
in and through Christ, right? All of us
will have our time of redemption. But
there's a reason that this kind of
doctrine of the apocuses has not been as
popular in the Christian West as it has
been in the east, Christian East. And
there's kind of a whole history there.
Um, and by the way, when I say Christian
East, I'm thinking of like uh Christians
in like like Russian Eastern theology
and Orthodoxy, uh, Ukrainian,
um, and I guess some others there, but
kind of that, you know, we think Eastern
Europe and even farther over. Um, as
well as kind of the Middle East, like
for example, um, someone I've drawn from
quite a bit is St. Isaac the Syrian. Uh,
wonderful. I mean, if you read it, you'd
think like just like the most modern of
ideas, but he was writing thousand years
ago or more, you know, like just way
back. Um, but again, he's St. Isaac the
Syrian,
not St. Isaac the Western European, you
know what I mean? And there's a reason
for this. And I think uh it's honestly
that it's St. Augustine in a lot of ways
that he ended up having a huge influence
on the entire Christian West which when
you wonder kind of west I'm not even
just thinking geography but it's als
it's really Catholicism Protestantism
because he came kind of upstream of both
of those. So by influencing Catholicism
so heavily which the Christian Christian
east missed out on that because the
split between them had already happened.
Um well no I say that that's not that's
not true but um still I think he just
for various historical reasons he ended
up um hugely influencing the west they
kind of glammed onto his thought much
more um and then protestants kind of
threw uh uh Catholicism a lot of
Augustine so now I should say to I don't
want to pick on Augustine like he was a
genius u I mean his his thoughts on um
kind of sin being uh or evil really
being just a kind kind of um the the
kind of negative of the good or like not
not be being parasitic would be the word
parasitic upon the good, not actually
having any being in of itself. Um is
super helpful. His doctrines of the
trinity and such like really really
good. Um but he had some other stuff you
know his doctrine and take on original
sin um doctrine of election and his
reading of Romans nine. I just think ah
it's a disaster. It's a disaster
shambles so bad. That's another sermon.
um and uh which and in some other things
his doctrine of hell and such kind of
flowed from that. So for that reason
you'll notice in the series and even
just my preaching in general I just draw
a lot from the Christian East and uh
this is this is why it's not because I
think the Christian East is some perfect
tradition but I do just think it's it's
better. So okay so why does this matter
for our series? Well, another kind of
area where the Christian East I I think
is helpful is in um what's known as the
doctrine of anthropology. Basically,
just its understanding of the human
being. Like what's our nature? Like who
who are we? Um how did God create us?
And uh in Christian uh Eastern Christian
theology, there is a kind of a more of a
tendency to think of humanity as one.
Kind of a a oneness underneath the
surface of things. Whereas it's no
surprise anyone the Christian West and
really just western thought in general
like we are I mean hey even good
Americans you know we're like
individualists
through and through and through. True. I
mean, you could even call it today like
almost a hyper individualism. Like kind
of to the point because I do think
there's something good things to be said
about certain individualistic thoughts,
but boy, we get like we're almost barely
responsible
like for or really not even to one
another anymore hardly. You know what I
mean? Like the the sense of community
and connection and all that is like it's
really, you know, it's dissipated. And
uh so that I think has really played out
and kind of flowing from that kind of
hyper autonomous individualistic
uh view of the human being has been um a
view of the human will as basically hey
as a good individual I can will whatever
the heck I want. That's you know just
how it goes. Uh and so you say well does
that have to do with hell and judgment
and such? Well, I think that view of the
human being as very autonomous and
separate and willing whatever I want,
um, it tends to really push against
everything I've been talking about in
this series of God wants to save all. I
mean, even the title message, right?
We're in this together.
We're in this together. You can see
we're in the West. It's kind of like,
no, we're not. You know what I mean?
Like, no, we're actually not in this
together. We I I am in this. It's me and
God. me and Jesus and you know everyone
else just they're kind of on their own
little journeys you know um and I think
that it kind of yeah it's it's a little
tricky like in essence even those who
would be inclined in kind of the
Christian west to actually agree with a
lot of um where I and other Christians
are coming from on a lot of this uh like
in for example they don't want to see
hell as like eternal conscious torment
and and such um but still they would um
they would say like, well, but there's
there's still this place, right, for the
in for the individual to kind of make
their own decisions and such, and you
can't push back on that. So, with that
in mind, what I want to do in in this
message is kind of give you um kind of
to gently kind of unpack and push back
on kind of two kind of more western
thoughts on like judgment and last
things and hell and separation from God
and all that that I think um yeah, I
want to to kind of help us think that
through uh and and kind of push back on
it. So, we got two of those tonight. The
first is um what's known as the free
will defense of hell. This I think will
be very familiar if as at least as I
unpack it you'll be like ah yeah I
thought something like this. So the free
will defense of hell is the belief that
an eternal hell or again separation from
God not necessarily this idea of like
eternal conscious torment uh must remain
alive option because God gave humans
free will. This means the right to
choose any end which means like purpose
tell us goal a human may desire
including here's the key including the
desire to be forever separated from God.
Can you see where that starts to play
out in our kind of thinking about last
things? So in short, the idea is
basically hell must kind of eternally
remain an option. In other words, we
can't say that all will be saved. Um not
because God doesn't will it.
In fact, um like they might even agree
with say 2 Peter 3:9 which talks about
how God desires all to repent. God
doesn't desire that anyone should
perish. Uh but the kind of logic goes,
"Yeah, but there may be those who resist
to the bitter end."
A good example of this would be Rob Bell
and his wonderful book, Love Wins. I
really like this book. On this one
point, though, I do disagree with Bell,
but here's kind of how he frames it. Um
he says, "Love demands freedom. It
always has. It always will. We're free
to resist, to reject, and rebel against
God's ways for us. We can have all the
hell we want.
Belle's a good writer. I mean, that's a
good way to frame, right? Can you see
here? This is um Yeah, there's there's
something to this, right? And it's and
it and I do agree this is like an
improvement for sure on hell as God's
horror chamber of tortures or something.
You know what I mean? Like, okay. Yeah,
this that's a definitely a step in the
right direction, I think. Um but uh yeah
but I do wonder if it goes far enough
but still right um yeah I think it's
it's in kind of the general right
direction. In fact, Bell's view is quite
poetically um put by CS Lewis, kind of
seconded seconded by him in his
wonderful book, The Great Divorce, which
I put off reading for many years because
I thought was a book about marriage and
nope, actually it's uh the subtitle, if
I just read the subtitle, it's about
like heaven and hell and es it's all the
stuff we've been talking about
basically, honestly. And it's another
beautiful book. Powerful had me back
before I found out about the apocases
and all that stuff. This was kind of
like it was like I don't know water in a
desert for me. It was a really
thoughtful book. Um but again Lewis kind
of puts it this way. He says, "I
willingly believe that the damned are in
one sense successful rebels to the end.
That the doors of hell are locked on the
inside."
So here, right, the vision again, it's
not this rather callous image of Christ
the judge, you know, who's like, "I
don't care if you're sorry. it's too
late now, you know, and like th th th th
th th th th th th th th th th th th th
th th th th th th th th th th throws in
the dungeon and throws away the keys or
something, you know. No, no. Um the
image here is broken souls who say, God,
we want nothing to do with you,
right? We have our free will and you
cannot take us take it from us. We've
got our rights. You can't go bossing us
around. We don't like you. We don't love
you. and we certainly do not want to
spend all eternity with you. So, we'll
just stay here in no man's land. Thank
you very much.
Now, aside from the fact, I don't know,
something about this scenario just
strikes me as very unlikely. I mean,
like presumably these folks are sort of
looking at Christ face to face and
whatever mysterious, you know, end of
days things that will mean. Uh, and I
don't know, the scenario strikes me, you
know, just a little like strange. They'd
be like folding their arms and just
being like, "No, I don't love I don't
want, you know, something weird about
that." But, um, I think this view it
deserves more than just saying like, "I
don't know. Seems unlikely, you know."
So, what I'd like to do is kind of
critique the notion of the will
happening here. Um, because I think it
is a more kind of modern understanding
of the will. And the more classical
Christian understanding, I think, can be
helpful um, in this regard. So what's
the the classical Christian
understanding of the will and freedom is
that every creature is free to pursue
and become what it was created by God to
pursue and become.
However, when it or when we fail to will
this, it immediately falls not into some
alternative freedom but actually into
bondage.
So the vision here in essence is that
God creates everything with this kind of
this telos to use that word again this
kind of purpose this end and
uh we have free will to the degree that
we are each of us kind of in our own
ways living into that vision. Now you
might wonder what's that what's that
vision? I think it's probably something
like what Jesus talked about where he
said the most important commandment is
to love God and love others. So I might
kind of tentatively define the human
telos as like growing into loving union
with God and all things, right? Kind of
broad enough there that it's not like
locking you into some very specific life
path of like God's will is that I live
on this street and I do this, you know.
Um it's a little it's kind of broad like
just when we're moving in that
direction, we're like in the in the flow
of God um so to speak, right? Um at the
same time, when we aren't willing that,
then whether we intend to or not, we're
actually falling into a kind of
unfreedom.
So like for example um 1 Corinthians
3:17 says, "Now the Lord is the spirit
and where the spirit of the Lord is,
there is freedom." Right? So as long as
I'm kind of moving into pure love and
joy and peace and patience and kindness,
goodness, gentleness, faithfulness,
self-control, right? That's freedom. The
minute I step away from all that into a
kind of will like selfishness or a greed
or lust or envy or hatred or whatever,
I've stepped again not into some
alternative path of the freedom of my
will, but I'm actually um I've stepped
into a sort of bondage.
I've used this metaphor before, but it's
a bit like when we see um our drug
addict friend,
uh freely choose their drug,
right? And in that moment, um like their
life, their relationships are all
falling to pieces. And no matter how
much they say to us with the mouth part
of them, you know, I'm free. I'm doing
what I want.
We know at some profound level they are
not free no matter how much they you
know demand that um they really they
really are and and this is why you know
we'll um even sometimes stage like an
extreme circumstances like stage an
intervention for someone you know and
say like look
you're not free like I'm free like no
you aren't you need to go get clean you
know and we insist on them uh going to
rehab and and such such so kind of seen
from this standpoint. Um I think when we
start to reimagine what you know hell is
um it's it's not the place where God
says even you know hey I have chosen you
but you have not chosen me and that's
okay you can just go off into no man's
land you know for all eternity because
that's what love would require. Um I
think more along the lines of Pel is
divine rehab.
Um
in essence it's this kind of cosmic
intervention
that in the moment someone may swear
they do not need but actually uh in the
end it's it's really it's trying to set
them free. Like it's sort of that
experience. Guess we even had these this
in our life, you know, where like we'll
go through something so hard and we'll
come out the other side and we'll be
like, "Oh my gosh, I couldn't see it in
the moment." But like I was so unfree. I
was so bound up. I needed my friends to
like come around me and say, "We insist.
We insist you go to me." You know, like
I needed that moment so then I could
actually get free and then only in
retrospect see, oh my gosh, I was in
bondage the whole time, right? I was
blind but now I see. So in short, I I
don't think hell will be um locked from
either the outside or the inside. Uh in
fact, it may be helpful not to think of
hell so much as a place at all. Uh as it
may ultimately be simply a state, a kind
of a certain a person's kind of a soul's
experience of the love of God. An
experience that at first is uh is
difficult, right? As we talked about
last week, all that is not love uh burns
away, so to speak. But it's that same
spiritual flame of love that
illuminates, that glorifies, that
transfigures us just like Christ on the
mount was transfigured, radiating with
the light and glory of God. So the
scriptures promise we too will be
transfigured because this is what we've
been created for. So that's the the
first thing. Um just some thoughts on
that that kind of uh free will defense.
The second is about annihilationism. So
the annihilationist view of hell agrees
that hell is not a place or a state of
eternal conscious torment um but rather
the destruction of a wayward soul.
Perhaps you've heard of this. So in this
view the the souls of the damned are
snuffed out like a wick.
So you're but not tortured for all
eternity. Right? Again, it's not it's
not hell as eternal conscious torment,
but it's just if you're with, you know,
sort of like going back to Matthew 25,
the separation of the sheep and the
goats. And if you're the goat, well,
then you get, you know, cast into hell
and then
just gone, just disintegrate, you know.
Um, so that's kind of the the
annihilationist view. And um
I think
the challenge here I think it's coming
back to the the opening of my message. I
think it's framing things too
individualistically.
Right? In essence uh I don't think
salvation is really in the end a kind of
individualistic affair. I I think that
though we may not perceive it on the
surface of things, we actually are one
body that my own salvation and joy are
intimately bound up with the salvation
and joy of my neighbor. Right? In
essence, as the saying goes, none of us
is free in the final and ultimate sense
until all of us are free. And I think
though this is another challenge, right,
to kind of western American minds when
it comes to salvation because we're just
so used to thinking in individualistic
terms. We're often taught from a very
young age that the most important
question we can answer is, do you
believe in Jesus? Do you repent of your
sins? Do you embrace the saving
knowledge of God? If so good because
that way what you can be saved
even if others are not right that way
you can be on God's good side
even if others are not on God's good
side now to be clear I do think there is
some sense of individual judgment again
we touched on that last week Matthew 25
and other passages there's an element of
that um but I would say this, we're
we're judged by works individually, but
we are saved by grace communally.
And this is why if you kind of zoom out,
there's so many texts which speak of us
as one body, one people. Even our
opening scripture, right, has a a sort
of communal judgment and a communal
salvation.
For God has bound everyone over to
disobedience so that he may have mercy
on them all. Right? Christ died for uh
sinners to kind of use the old language,
right? But that's not some subset of
humanity. Like, oh, just those bad
people. You're like, no, no, that would
just be humanity. And that's why, as um
Romans 3:23 puts it, for all have sinned
and fallen short of the glory of God.
What's not so often memorized or
preached is Romans 3:24, "And all are
justified freely by his grace through
the redemption that came by Christ
Jesus.
Sergius Bulgov in his wonderful book,
The Bride of the Lamb, puts it this way.
He says, "Therefore, the idea of two
humankinds divided and separated from
each other at the last judgment do not
correspond to the fullness and
connectedness of reality.
Humankind is one.
It is one in Adam and one in Christ. One
in his body in the church. So we being
many are one body in Christ and everyone
members of another one one members of
another. Romans 12:5. This unity is
expressed in love. Whether one member
suffers, all the members suffer with it.
Or one member be honored. All the
members rejoice with it. 1 Corinthians
12:26.
For we are members one of another.
Ephesians 4:25. Members of his body, of
his flesh, and of his bones. Ephesians
5:30. Right. It's it's texts like that
that kind of push back
on this western kind of individualism,
right? This idea that I'm separate from
those people.
No, no. The world is like an ocean,
everything connected, ripples going out
affecting everything and everyone else
because there is a oneness beneath the
surface of things.
Bulgoff continues, "Can it be that this
law of love will lose its power after
the last judgment? Can it be that not
only the sickness but even the spiritual
death of many members?" Think again of
annihilationism and such that it will
cease to provoke the compassion of
active praying love on the part of the
healthy members.
know is the answer that must follow from
a clear statement of the question. In
that sense in which one can speak of
them, the torments of hell inevitably
extend not only to those who are
condemned but also to the entire church
to all humankind.
We can forget that all are saved with
all just as all are condemned with all
and all are responsible for all. only if
we understand esquetology exclusively
from the criminal point of view. In
other words, like if some are some are
guilty and some are innocent and
especially if we understand salvation
individualistically
if not egotistically.
How could a mother remain indifferent to
the predition of her son
or a son remain indifferent to the fate
of his mother? Can the diverse personal
ties of love that connects humankind be
frayed to the point where our very
memories of one another are lost?
Such a picture of mutual annihilationism
in love is a terrible nightmare. A
blasphemous slander against the God of
love in the church.
On the contrary, the existence of a hell
with eternal torments affects all
humankind. the whole body of the church
like a common malady. The presence of
hell becomes a reality for all creation.
Therefore, even for the righteous,
heavenly bliss comes only after the
expulsion of hell from the world. For he
Christ must reign till he hath put all
enemies under his feet, that God may be
all in all.
All perish and are saved together,
although differently by Christ's
redemptive sacrifice which creature le
can neither negate nor limit. And like
the pitying heart of the mother of God,
the church's love also does not know any
limits.
I think that's a beautiful summation of
the gospel.
And I love his insight too into memory.
And another place he calls it the
alleged amnesia of the righteous.
He's like, "Will the righteous in heaven
suddenly forget their friends and family
who have not yet passed through that
fire? Will they be just indifferent to
their fate? Like, ah, who cares? I I'm
just happy I'm in heaven."
No. No. None of us is truly saved in the
deepest sense. fully healed, restored,
made whole until the entire body of
creation is healed, restored, made
whole.
I'll close with this. In the uh the
Buddhist tradition, there's a tradition
known as or the notion of the the bodhic
sattva. And this is someone who
basically intentionally holds off on
their final enlightenment. um which
would basically mean that they would no
longer be reborn in this world. Kind of
put in Christian terms, we might say
they they hold off on their final
merging or union with God. But they
request that they not reach that stage
and that instead they be reborn on earth
again and again and again and again to
help all other beings reach their
enlightenment.
And only after the very last being has
entered and their prayer is that they
too may enter.
I think that's
stunning. That's beautiful
and because and so much of like the
heart of that I get certain aspects of
the doctrine of the reincarnation and
such wouldn't jive so easily with
Christian theology but the heart of it
is like so in alignment with the
apoctosasis
the healing restoration of all things
right that that it's it's exactly the
hope of Christians right which at its
best is not simply a oh God Save me.
Save me. God, me. Me. Right. This is
like not the best of Christian thought.
Instead, the prayer of Christians is
what? Oh, God. Save what? Who?
Us.
Save us.
Save all of us together. In fact, may
not one of us be saved in the final and
ultimate sense until all of us go in
together.
That's Christ. I think that's the great
Christian hope. In the name of the
Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held the loaf of
bread and he broke it and he said, "Take
it. Eat. This is my body. It's broken
for you." And then he held up the cup of
wine. He said, "Take it. Drink. This is
my blood. It's shed for you. Whenever
you eat this bread, whenever you drink
this cup, remember me." And so as we
come forward tonight, that's the great
mystery that we're participating in.
We're connecting with we're um coming
into contact with Christ in a beautiful
way. So the way what we'll participate
in communion is we'll just go kind of
row by row starting here at the front
and forming one line um here in the
middle. We practice what's called an
open table. So if you're here tonight,
you'd like to participate regardless of
your exact theology, uh you're you're
welcome to come and participate if you
would like to. At the same time, there's
no if you'd rather not. The red is wine,
the white is grape juice, and finally,
you can just partake whenever and
however you'd like. Some people take
immediately, some come and kneel at the
front. Um, but you can just partake of
the elements on your own. So, this is
the table,
not the church,
but of the Lord, and it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more. So come
come you who have much faith and you who
have little. You who have been here
often and you who have not been here
long. You who have tried to follow and
you who feel like you failed. Come. Come
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you. And it's his will that
those who want to meet him should meet
him here. Come to the table.
[Music]
I feel like in our um current day and
age, you know, there's been like a big
shift and a necessary one, but towards,
you know, like self-care, self-love,
make sure you're taking care of
yourself. And um somewhere in the
middle, you know, we've we kind of need
like that pull back to remember
um the beauty of community and and
turning our eyes outside of oursel and
looking to the needs of each other and
the people around us. And um tonight we
wanted to just close out with a blessing
that we um want to share with one
another over our community. And it's
much like the blessing that um the Lord
said to Moses in Numbers. He said, "Tell
Aaron and his sons that this is how you
bless the Israelites, your community.
The Lord bless you and keep you. Make
his face shine upon you and be gracious
to you. The Lord turn his face towards
you and give you peace. So they will put
my name on the Israelites and I will
bless them."
And just like that, we want to bless
each other tonight as we go out. Um, so
if you guys would like to sing along
with us, you are more than welcome to.
The words will be on the screen. Um, if
you would like to just sit and receive
this as we speak it out to you, that's
great as well. But I hope that you go
feeling blessed tonight.
[Music]
I wish upon you peace.
I wish upon you grace.
I wish for less of what you want and
more of what you need.
I wish upon you an old life with a heart
that stays young.
[Music]
But most of all, I wish upon you love.
I wish upon you truth
when all you feel is down.
I hope you know that both open mind
still knows when to shut things out.
I wish upon you a brave heart that will
always rise above.
But most of all, I wish upon you love
as the sun sets and the moon begins to
rise.
[Music]
So even in the darkness, you'll find a
light.
You'll find a light.
[Music]
You'll find the light.
>> Yes. Even in the darkness, you will find
a light.
I wish upon you an easy life. I wish
upon you hard times. I hope you know
that both joy and pain each need their
moment to shine. Wish you ears that are
quick to listen and you're slow to use
that time.
But most of all, I wish upon you love.
>> And as the sun sets, will the moon
begins to rise?
>> So even in the darkness, you'll find the
light.
You'll find the light.
[Music]
Yes. Even in the darkness,
you'll find the light.
[Music]
We're so glad you joined us this
evening.
If you are new, we would love for you to
fill out a card on the table on your way
out or just scan the QR code and fill
out a visitor's card.
Generosity is a key aspect of life and
adoration in worship. To give
financially,
you can also scan the QR code.
If you call the table home and have not
yet explored our many ministries, we
would love for you to do that. You can
go on the website and um check out all
the fabulous ministries. We have our AV
ministry.
We have our kids ministry
and we have our host team ministry which
sets up and tears down. We have our
fabulous praise and worship. So if
something is calling you, we'd love to
just re reach out and answer any
questions that you may have.
All right, I'm going to send you out
with this benediction.
You can hold your hand out in a posture
to receive
or just open your hearts to these words.
You
are a child of God.
are a child
of God.
This is true on your best day
and this is true on your worst day.
So as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between,
go filled with the assurance
that you are loved,
that you are cherished,
and you are accepted.
just as you are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with. Be blessed.
Have a great week. And I hope to see you
back here next Sunday. Good night.
[Music]
As the sun sets, when the moon begins to
rise.
>> So even in the darkness, you'll find the
light.
>> You'll find the light.
[Music]
You'll find the light.
>> Yes. Even in the darkness,
you'll find the light.
[Music]
Thanks.